This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. For centuries, humans have looked up into the night sky and wondered, are we alone in the universe? The possibility of intelligent life elsewhere in the cosmos remains one of the great mysteries and one that I don't expect to see resolved in my lifetime. But for a brief period headed into the 20th century, much of the Western world believed that this question, Are we alone, had finally been answered.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。几个世纪以来，人类一直仰望夜空，好奇我们在宇宙中是否是孤独的？宇宙其他地方存在智慧生命的可能依然是最大的谜团之一，而且我预计在我有生之年这个谜团都不会解开。但在20th世纪初的一段短暂时期里，大部分西方世界都相信，“我们是否孤独”这个问题终于得到了解答。
Because we had discovered evidence of an advanced alien civilization living on Mars. Alexander Graham Bell wrote that he thought there was no question that there was intelligent life on Mars. There were professors at Harvard and Yale and Brown, Ivy League institutions who were totally on board with this. To the point where in the end of 1907, the Wall Street Journal said the biggest news of the year was proof of intelligent life on Mars. This is David Barron, a science journalist and author of a new book called The Martians, the true story of an alien craze that captured turn-of-the-century America. David says that news of extraterrestrial life at that time permeated the culture. Martians were everywhere.
因为我们发现了生活在火星上的高等外星文明的证据。亚历山大·格雷厄姆·贝尔写道，他认为火星上毫无疑问存在智慧生命。哈佛、耶鲁和布朗大学的教授们——那些常春藤盟校的学者们——完全赞同这一观点。以至于在1907年底，《华尔街日报》称年度最大新闻是火星存在智慧生命的证据。这是大卫·巴伦，一名科学记者兼新书《火星人：席卷世纪之交美国的狂热外星狂潮的真实故事》的作者。大卫说，当时关于外星生命的消息渗透了整个文化。火星人无处不在。
You'd see Martians depicted in Broadway plays and vaudeville skits. There were songs about the Martians in Tin Pan Alley music. There were Martians in advertising. There was a Martian in the comics, a guy named Mr. Skygack, from Mars who was in newspapers across the country. I recently spoke with David about his book, and so much of it still resonates with debates that we're having today about science, expertise, and truth.
你会看到百老汇戏剧和杂耍喜剧中都有火星人的身影。丁盘巷的音乐里有关于火星人的歌曲。广告里也有火星人。漫画里也有火星人，一个名叫“斯凯加克先生”的火星人出现在全国各地的报纸上。我最近和大卫聊了他的书，其中有很多内容至今仍与我们今天正在进行的关于科学、专业知识和真相的辩论产生共鸣。
The story he tells is one of mass delusion, about the dangers of unchecked speculation seeping into public discourse, and it's a drama that centers around the misplaced ambitions of one wealthy amateur astronomer who convinced the world, Martians were real. Here's my chat with David Barron. So your book centers on a character named Percival Lowell, and he's sort of the engine powering this idea of life on Mars. Could you talk about who Percival Lowell was?
他讲述的故事是一个关于集体妄想的故事，关于未加检查的猜测渗透进公共话语中的危险，这是一场以一个富有业余天文学家的错置野心为中心的戏剧，他让全世界相信火星人是真实的。以下是我与大卫·巴伦的对话。所以你的书围绕着一个名叫珀西瓦尔·洛厄尔的角色展开，他是推动火星生命这个概念的引擎。你能谈谈珀西瓦尔·洛厄尔是谁吗？
Well, so Lowell was an interesting man psychologically. Now, obviously, I never met him, and I'm not a psychoanalyst. But, you know, he clearly had a big ego and a fragile ego. So Percival Lowell came from one of the most prominent families in New England. The Lowell's of Massachusetts were incredibly wealthy, were big philanthropists, were big in the culture of Massachusetts and the United States. Percival graduated from Harvard, like all the men in the family did. He was the eldest son. And he had a lot of weight on his shoulders.
嗯，从心理学上讲，洛厄尔是一个有趣的人。当然，我从未见过他，我也不是精神分析学家。但是，你知道，他显然有着巨大的自我和脆弱的自我。珀西瓦尔·洛厄尔来自新英格兰最显赫的家族之一。马萨诸塞州的洛厄尔家族极其富有，是大慈善家，在马萨诸塞州和美国的文化中举足轻重。珀西瓦尔毕业于哈佛，就像家族里的所有男性一样。他是长子。他的肩上承担着沉重的压力。
He was a Lowell. His father had told him and his brother that they had to do something important with their lives. And so for a while he traveled. He was a writer. He was one of the very first Americans to go to Korea. He wrote a book about it. So he really made quite a name for himself as this kind of roving anthropologist. But as he approached the age of 40, he decided he wanted to become an astronomer.
他是一个洛厄尔。他的父亲曾告诉他和他的兄弟，他们的人生必须做一些重要的事情。因此他旅行了一段时间。他是一名作家。他是最早去朝鲜的美国人之一。他为此写了一本书。因此，作为这种四处游历的人类学家，他确实名声大噪。但当他接近40岁时，他决定成为一名天文学家。
And he had the wealth to do it in a big way. And he really, he became, in essence, the most famous astronomer of that time in America. And so when Lowell takes up astronomy, like, what is going on in the field? And maybe more specifically, what was going on with Mars? So there were big advances in astronomy in the 19th century telescopes were now getting quite large and sophisticated. And so astronomers by the late 19th century were getting a really good view of the surface of Mars. Now Mars, of course, is right next to us in terms of its orbit. But Earth and Mars only come close together once every 26 months.
他拥有实现这一目标的巨大财富。而且他确实在本质上成为了当时美国最著名的天文学家。那么当洛厄尔涉足天文学时，这个领域正在发生什么？或者更具体地说，火星上发生了什么？19th世纪天文学取得了重大进展，望远镜现在变得相当巨大和复杂。因此到19th世纪末，天文学家对火星表面有了非常好的观察。现在火星，当然，就其轨道而言就在我们旁边。但地球和火星每26个月才接近一次。
And about every 15 years, Earth and Mars come especially close together. And that's the time when you can really get a, through your telescope, see Mars in relatively good detail. Well, 1877 was one of those years. And there was an astronomer in Milan named Giovanni Skaaparelli, who decided he was going to create a new map of Mars. And night after night, he studied the planet, and he drew what he saw with precision. And when he came out with this map, Mars, first of all, looked very Earth-like. It had dark areas that were assumed to be oceans and light areas that were thought to be continents. But Scapparelli also saw these fine lines crisscrossing the light areas.
大约每15年，地球和火星就会格外接近。那是你真的可以通过望远镜以相对清晰的细节看到火星的时候。1877年就是这样的一年。米兰有一位名叫乔瓦尼·斯基帕雷利的的天文学家，他决定绘制一张新的火星地图。夜复一夜，他研究这颗行星，并精确地画出他所看到的东西。当他拿出这张地图时，火星首先看起来非常像地球。它有被认为是海洋的黑暗区域，以及被认为是大陆的光亮区域。但斯基帕雷利还看到这些纤细的线条交织穿过光亮区域。
And he imagined that they were waterways of some sort. So he called them canali, which in Italian means channels. They were water channels of some sort. Well, canale was translated or mistranslated into English as canals, which has a very different meaning. Yeah, like a channel or waterways naturally. occurring in the landscape, but a canal, like, that's made by something or someone. Right. They were a mystery.
他想象它们是某种水道。所以他称它们为canali，在意大利语中是渠道的意思。它们是某种水渠。好吧，canale被翻译或误翻译成英文的canals（运河），这有着非常不同的意思。是的，就像风景中自然产生的河道或水道，而运河，就像是某物或某人制造的。没错。这是一个谜。
No one knew what these lines that looked so straight that they seemed artificial might be. And it was Percival Lowell when he decided in 1894 to dedicate the next stage of his life to studying Mars, to becoming an astronomer, and he was going to solve the mystery of the canals. Right. And Lowell ultimately comes up with this grand theory. He says, not only are the canals real, but in fact, they're a massive planet.
没有人知道这些看起来如此笔直以至于似乎是人工的线条可能是什么。正是珀西瓦尔·洛厄尔在1894年决定将他人生的下一个阶段奉献给研究火星，成为一名天文学家，他要解开运河之谜。没错。而洛厄尔最终提出了这个宏大的理论。他说，这些运河不仅是真实的，而且事实上，它们是一个巨大的行星。
wide system created by an advanced alien civilization living on Mars, which is like crazy. But could you explain his thinking at the time? Right. So I know that today it sounds ridiculous. How could anyone take this seriously? But it was, I actually give him credit. It was a coherent theory that fit with a lot of ideas about Mars at the time that at least was worth investigating. So here was the theory. Mars, it was widely believed, was an older planet than Earth. So Mars hardened and became habitable before Earth did. So you might imagine that there was life on Mars before on Earth, that life on Mars became intelligent before life on Earth.
由生活在火星上的高级外星文明创造的广阔系统，这听起来太疯狂了。但你能解释一下他当时的想法吗？没错。所以我知道今天听起来很荒谬。怎么会有人把这当回事呢？但我实际上赞许他。这是一个连贯的理论，符合当时关于火星的许多想法，至少值得研究。所以理论是这样的。人们普遍认为，火星比地球更古老。因此火星在地球之前硬化并变得适合居住。所以你可能会想象火星上的生命比地球上的出现得早，火星上的生命比地球上的生命更早变得聪明。
So now Mars, it was thought, was in its dying phases. And it was known that Mars had polar ice caps. So if, in fact, there was intelligent life on Mars, and the water was running out, well, what you would need to do was tap the melt water from the ice cap and bring the water down to where your cities and your farms are. That's what he thought the canals were. This was a worldwide irrigation network that allowed the Martians to survive off the water from the ice caps. So it was a coherent theory, but he went into it wanting to prove himself right,
所以现在人们认为火星正处于衰亡阶段。而且众所周知火星有极地冰盖。所以，事实上，如果火星上存在智慧生命，而水正在耗尽，嗯，你需要做的是利用来自冰盖的融水，把水引到你的城市和农场所在的地方。他认为运河就是这个。这是一个全球灌溉网络，使火星人能够靠来自冰盖的水生存。所以这是一个连贯的理论，但他带着想证明自己正确的愿望去研究它，
which is kind of a mistake in science. Yeah. And Lowell, of course, has a lot of time and money at his disposal to prove himself right. So one of the first things he does is build this stay-of-the-art observatory out in Flagstaff, Arizona. And he starts looking at Mars through his big, expensive telescope and then drawing what he sees. But for Lowell, could you describe what are the obstacles of trying to look at the surface of Mars back in the 1800s? Yeah, I mean, we have to put out of our minds everything. we know about Mars today, because we've all seen high-resolution photos and videos of the surface
这在科学中算是一种错误。是的。当然，洛厄尔有大量的时间和金钱来证明自己是正确的。所以他做的第一件事就是在亚利桑那州弗拉格斯塔夫建造了这个先进的天文台。他开始通过他巨大而昂贵的望远镜观察火星，然后画出他看到的东西。但对于洛厄尔来说，你能描述一下在19世纪尝试观察火星表面有什么障碍吗？是的，我的意思是，我们必须抛开我们今天对火星所知的一切，因为我们都看过火星表面的高分辨率照片和视频
of Mars. We know what it looks like. But cast yourself back into the late 19th century, all we knew about Mars was what you could see through an earthbound telescope of a planet that at its closest is 35 million miles away. But more than that, you're looking through the Earth's atmosphere. It's like looking at the sky from the bottom of the ocean. This ocean of air distorts the light as it comes in. And so looking at Mars, even through a fine telescope, it tends to go in and out of focus. It wobbles. So you only have often just split second glimpses of clarity. So you have to stare at the planet over long, long periods to get these moments of clarity and then remember what you saw. And so those canals, it's not like you could stare at the
我们知道它是什么样子的。但把自己带回到19th世纪末，我们对火星的了解仅限于你通过地基望远镜能看到的关于一颗在最近时距离我们3500万英里的行星。不仅如此，你还要透过地球的大气层看。这就像在海底看天空。这种空气的海洋会使射入的光线发生扭曲。因此，即使通过优质望远镜观察火星，它往往也会时而对焦时而失焦。它会晃动。所以你通常只有极其短暂的清晰瞬间。因此你必须长时间盯着这颗行星以获得这些清晰的时刻，然后记住你所看到的。所以那些运河，并不是说你可以盯着
planet and you would just see this whole array of canals. No, you would just see this whole array of canals. No, you would see this fuzzy orange red orb in your telescope wobbling around and then suddenly you'd see a little bit came into focus and oh I saw some lines and you draw those and then you stare some more and you see see more of these lines so it was very very difficult to really get a sense of what was there and in the book you actually write about going to lowell's observatory yourself I did actually so in 2018 I went to the lowell observatory in flagstaff to look at through Lowell's very telescope at a time when Mars and Earth were exceptionally close. And just staring at this apricot-colored orb in the telescope, it really is sort of hypnotic. You just, you stare and you stare and you stare. And it's sometimes hard to know what you've seen and what you thought you saw, what you imagined you saw. And is he working with other folks that are sort of buttressing his claims?
这颗行星，你就会看到一整排的运河。不，你会看到一整排的运河。不，你会透过望远镜看到这个模糊的橙红色球体在晃动，然后突然你看到一点对焦了，哦，我看到了一些线，你把它们画下来，然后你再盯着看一会儿，你会看到更多这些线条，所以要真正了解那里有什么是非常非常困难的，而且在书中你确实写了自己去洛厄尔天文台的经历。我确实去了。事实上，在2018年，我去了弗拉格斯塔夫的洛厄尔天文台，在火星和地球极其接近的时候，通过洛厄尔自己的望远镜进行观察。仅仅盯着望远镜里这个杏色的球体，它确实有点催眠。你只是，你盯着，你盯着，你盯着。有时很难弄清楚你看到的是什么，你以为你看到了什么，你想象你看到了什么。他在和支持他主张其他人一起工作吗？
or what is how, is he alone in this field? Well, so he had, when he established the Lowell Observatory, he actually hired away a couple of Harvard astronomers to help him first found the observatory and then he kept one on his staff. And so this assistant of his, who was a fine astronomer named Andrew Ellicott-Douglas, A.E. Douglas, you know, he went along with his boss. He saw the lines too. He mapped the lines.
还是怎么回事，他在这个领域是孤单的吗？嗯，所以当他建立洛厄尔天文台时，他实际上雇佣了几位哈佛的天文学家来帮助他首先建立天文台，然后他留用了一位在员工名单上。所以他的这个助手，一位名叫安德鲁·埃利科特·道格拉斯（A.E. Douglas）的出色天文学家，你知道，他顺从了他的老板。他也看到了这些线条。他还绘制了这些线条。
But over time, he started to question, whether the lines were real or if they were illusory. And as soon as he expressed any doubt about it, Lowell summarily fired him, which says a lot about Lowell that he did not like to be questioned. Yeah. So when Percival Lowell sees these channels, which he posits, are canals, are they immediately accepted as a thing in the scientific community or is there a debate about them? Oh, there was huge debate. So these lines on Mars, these canals on Mars, were very hard to see. You know, there were astronomers at other observatories with excellent telescopes who didn't see the lines. And even Scaparrelli said they're not always there. You don't always see them. You have to have the
但随着时间的推移，他开始质疑这些线条是真实的还是虚幻的。一旦他对此表达任何怀疑，洛厄尔就毫不留情地解雇了他，这说明了很多关于洛厄尔不喜欢被质疑的问题。是的。因此，当珀西瓦尔·洛厄尔看到这些他假设为运河的渠道时，它们在科学界是被立即接受的，还是存在关于它们的争论？哦，有巨大的争论。所以火星上的这些线条，火星上的这些运河，非常难以看到。你知道，其他天文台拥有极好望远镜的天文学家并没有看到这些线条。甚至斯基帕雷利也说它们并不总是存在。你并不总是能看到它们。你必须拥有
right viewing conditions. And to make it even more complicated, the lines came and went. So it seemed that they came and went with the seasons on Mars. It was all very mysterious. But, you know, when you have one astronomer saying, I don't see them and another who says I do, well, the one who doesn't see them, you can say, well, your eyesight isn't good enough, your telescope isn't good enough. Your observatory is located in a place with bad air overhead that you can't really get a clear view of Mars. So those who saw them kind of had the upper hand against those who didn't see them. And so how does Lowell ultimately start pushing his grand theory out to the public? So Lowell was incredibly articulate. He was considered an excellent speaker. He came from a prominent family. People would listen to him. He had all sorts of means of conveying his ideas. So first of all, in Boston at the time, there was a popular organization called the Lowell Institute, which brought in prominent speakers to give free lectures to the public. And of course, this was founded by one of his late cousins. In fact, it was over. overseen by Lowell's very father,
正确的观看条件。为了使情况更加复杂，这些线条时隐时现。所以看起来它们随着火星上的季节而出现和消失。这一切都非常神秘。但是，你知道，当一个天文学家说我没有看到它们，而另一个说我看到了，嗯，对于那个没看到的人，你可以说，嗯，你的视力不够好，你的望远镜不够好。你的天文台位于一个头顶空气不好的地方，你无法真正获得火星的清晰视野。所以那些看到它们的人在那些没有看到它们的人面前占了上风。那么洛厄尔最终是如何开始向公众推销他的宏大理论的呢？所以洛厄尔口才极佳。他被认为是一个出色的演讲者。他来自一个显赫的家族。人们会听他的。他有各种各样传达自己想法的方法。首先，当时在波士顿有一个名为洛厄尔研究所的受欢迎的组织，它邀请杰出的演讲者向公众发表免费演讲。当然，这是由他的一位已故表亲创立的。事实上，它是由
Lowell was invited to speak about Mars to the Lowell Institute, which actually had its lectures in a room, a big auditorium at MIT. So he reached audiences that way. Lowell then published the text of his talks in the Atlantic Monthly. The founding editor of the Atlantic Monthly was James Russell Lowell, also a relative. And so he was very good at presenting his ideas to the public.
洛厄尔的亲生父亲监管的，洛厄尔应邀在洛厄尔研究所发表关于火星的演讲，该研究所实际上在麻省理工学院的一个房间，一个大礼堂里举办演讲。因此他以这种方式接触到了受众。然后洛厄尔在《大西洋月刊》上发表了他的演讲文本。该杂志的创始主编是詹姆斯·拉塞尔·洛厄尔，也是一位亲戚。因此他非常擅长向公众展示他的想法。
And it doesn't take long before you have a few lectures, you have a few, you know, articles in the Atlantic that journalism, he's not connected to, just like takes this up and is very excited by these ideas. Can you talk about what the papers were like at this time and how they kind of use the Mars craze to sell papers? So this was a time when there was a revolution underway in America's newspapers. So the famous publishers Joseph Pulitzer and William Randolph Hearst were basically inventing. the tabloid press, which at the time was called the yellow press, and they latched on to anything that was sensationalistic. Well, the idea of life on Mars fit right in. And so the Pulitzer and Hearst newspapers, when there was talk of the Martians, they really pushed it out onto the public. And they latched onto what Lowell was saying. And so that helped to propel this idea
没过多久，你做了几次演讲，你在《大西洋月刊》上发表了几篇文章，新闻界与此无关，只是接受了这一点，并对这些想法感到非常兴奋。你能谈谈当时的报纸是什么样的，以及它们如何利用火星狂潮来卖报纸的吗？所以这是一个美国报纸正在经历革命的时期。因此，著名的出版商约瑟夫·普利策和威廉·伦道夫·赫斯特基本上在发明
out into the general populace. Yeah. And beyond the press, other prominent scientists and academics, are really pushing Lowell's theory too, including Nicola Tesla. So how does he fit into all this? So Nicola Tesla was a genius who changed the world. He also was an eccentric guy. And in 1890, after having done all this work with the distribution of electricity by wires, he was getting interested in what was called wireless, what today we would call radio. And so he set up an experimental laboratory in Colorado in 1890 to study.
黄色新闻，当时被称为黄色新闻，他们抓住任何耸人听闻的东西不放。火星生命的想法非常切合主题。因此，普利策和赫斯特的报纸，当有关于火星人的讨论时，他们真正将其推向了公众。他们抓住了洛厄尔所说的话。因此，这有助于将这个想法推向大众。是的。除了新闻界，其他杰出的科学家和学者也在大力推销洛厄尔的理论，包括尼古拉·特斯拉。那么他是如何融入这一切的呢？所以尼古拉·特斯拉是一位改变世界的奇才。他也是一个古怪的人。1890年，在做了所有用电线配电的工作后，他开始对所谓的无线电感兴趣，也就是我们今天所说的无线电。因此，他在1890年在科罗拉多建立了一个实验实验室来研究
how electrical waves were transmitted through the atmosphere. This was before, there was anything, there were no radio stations, but you could listen to natural electromagnetic radiation like from lightning. And Tesla one night, alone in the lab, was listening to the sounds of distant lightning and other things, and he heard the weirdest thing in his receiver. It was this signal that repeated in triplets. It was sort of a click, click, click, click, click. over and over again. And he pondered for a while what could possibly be causing it. And Tesla eventually
电波是如何通过大气层传输的。这是在没有任何东西之前，没有广播电台，但你可以听到自然的电磁辐射，比如闪电。特斯拉在一个晚上，独自在实验室里，听着远处的闪电和其他东西的声音，他在接收器里听到了最奇怪的事情。这是一个以三联体重复的信号。这有点像克λικ，克λικ，克λικ，克λικ，克λικ。一遍又一遍。他思索了一会儿，究竟是什么可能导致了这种情况。最终特斯拉
decided there was no natural explanation. The most logical explanation was this was Percival Lowell's Martians sending a signal to the earth. And when Tesla announced this to the world, the craze just completely took off. And one of the things that you do in the book is sort of cast yourself back to this time period, and you flat out say that you probably would have gotten wrapped up in this craze around Mars, too. So can you talk a little bit about that? Like, what is happening around the turn of the century that made life on Mars feel like it made complete sense? Well, so this was the period that today we remember as the Gilded Age, which makes it sound like it was this glittering, wonderful time. It really wasn't for many, many people, right? We know that there was this tremendous divide between
决定没有自然的解释。最符合逻辑的解释是这是珀西瓦尔·洛厄尔的火星人在向地球发送信号。当特斯拉向全世界宣布这一点时，这股热潮彻底爆发了。你在书中做的事情之一就是把自己带回到这段时期，你斩钉截铁地说你可能也会卷入这场围绕火星的狂潮中。所以你能稍微谈谈那个吗？世纪之交发生了什么让火星生命感觉完全说得通？嗯，所以这是我们今天被称为镀金时代的时期，这听起来像是一个闪闪发光的、美好的时代。对许许多多人来说其实并非如此，对吧？我们知道极少数极其富有的人和绝大多数绝望贫困的人之间存在着巨大的鸿沟。这是一个充满暴力劳工骚乱和无政府主义的时期。威廉·麦金莱，威廉·麦金莱总统在美国被一名无政府主义者暗杀。因此人们有一种世界正在崩塌的感觉，地球上的事情并不是那么顺利。而珀西瓦尔·洛厄尔理论的一部分，
the few exceptionally rich and the many who were desperately poor. This was a time when there was violent labor unrest, when there was anarchism. William McKinley, President William McKinley was assassinated by an anarchist in the United States. So there was a sense that the world was falling apart, that things were not going so well on earth. And part of the, of Percival Lowell's theory,
是火星人在智力和技术上不仅领先于我们，而且在道德上也比我们更好。毕竟，如果这个星球已经开发了这个全球灌溉网络，那就意味着各地的每个人都在合作。北极的火星人正在与赤道上的火星人合作。那里肯定没有交战的国家。这是一个完整的星球
was that the Martians were not only in advance of us intellectually and in terms of their technology, but they were better than us morally. After all, if the planet has developed this global irrigation network, that means everyone everywhere is working together. The Martians up in the Arctic are working together with those on the equator. That there must not be warring nations. This is an entire planet.
作为一个整体聚集在一起。对于当时的许多人来说，这是一个非常吸引人的想法，认为，也许有可能创造一个暴力更少、众生合作的世界。不仅如此，如果我们能与火星人取得联系，也许他们可以解决我们在地球上面临的问题。你知道，我认为如果你今天告诉人们宇宙中存在智慧生命的证据。我想人们会这样想：如果我们有那样的证据，它将对我们所相信的一切产生震撼地球的影响。它会颠覆神学。它会颠覆我们在宇宙中的自我意识，我们的科学意识。
that's pulled together as one. And that was a very appealing notion to people at that time, to think that, well, maybe it's possible to create a world where there's less violence, where beings are working together. And more than that, if we could just get in touch with the Martians, maybe they could solve our problems here on Earth. You know, I think if you were to tell people today that there was evidence of intelligent life in the universe. And I think people think about it. it is like, well, if we had evidence of that, it would be so like earth-shaking to everything we believe. It would upend theology. It would upend our sense of self in the universe, our sense of science.
而我们实际上经历过这种情况，人们大多相信这一点。而且似乎它并没有产生颠覆一切的那种影响。它真的很完美地融入了每个人对上帝、宗教和科学的看法中。你能谈谈这个吗，它是如何如此美妙地被同化到我们的世界观中的？是的，我的意思是，这真的让我感到惊讶，因为你会认为，当时确实有人猜测这会导致传统宗教崩溃。我的意思是，你知道，如果基督来到地球拯救我们的灵魂，基督也去火星了吗？我的意思是，这似乎有点牵强。但实际上，并没有，神学家和神职人员能够将这些想法融入其中，并且并没有真正觉得它动摇了他们的信仰。
And we actually went through this where people mostly believe this. And it seems like it didn't have that type of effect where it upended everything. It really just sort of like it kind of fit in nicely with everyone's view of God. God and religion and science. Could you talk about that, like how much it was so kind of nicely metabolized into our worldview? Yeah, I mean, that really surprised me because you would think that, and there were people at the time speculating that this would cause traditional religion to crumble. I mean, you know, if Christ came to Earth to save our souls, did Christ go to Mars too? I mean, that seems to be stretching things. But actually, no, theologians and clergy were able to incorporate these ideas and not really, they didn't feel that it undermined their beliefs.
如果有什么不同的话，他们找到了让它放大自己信仰的方法。这将只是更多供上帝俯瞰的世界和众生。它只是展示了上帝的荣耀甚至比我们想象的还要伟大。是的。所以它不仅仅是火星生命的奇妙之处。这真的是关于希望，以及我们希望我们的世界成为什么样子。嗯，我觉得这是我在研究那个时期时发现的大重大、深奥的发现之一。
And if anything, they found ways for it to amplify their beliefs. This would just even more worlds, more beings for God to oversee. And it just showed the glory of God to be even greater than we imagined. Yeah. So it isn't just like the G-Wiz aspect of Marsan life. It really is about hope. and how we want our, you know, the world to be. Well, that was one of the big, deep discoveries I felt that I made in studying that period.
因为我一开始觉得，这只是一件非常有趣的事情。你能相信当时人们真的相信有火星人吗？但后来我开始发现它触及了我们所有人的某些非常深层的、普遍的欲望。当我发现这篇1909年在全国各地（许多报纸）刊登的报纸文章时，这一点变得非常清晰，当时人们正在认真讨论寻找与火星交流的方法。所以这篇文章的标题是：火星可能会回答的问题。所以这是一份当我们最终与火星取得联系时应该问他们的问题清单。嗯，你可能会认为我们会问他们关于建造运河的实际问题，或者也许是如何改进莱特兄弟的飞机。
Because I first went into a thing, this is just, this is a rollicking good tale. Can you believe it that at that time people really believed that they were Martians? But then I came to see that it spoke to some very deep, universal desires of all of us. And this really, this really became clear when I found this newspaper article that ran across the country, many newspapers in 1909, at a time when there was serious discussion of coming up with a way to communicate with Mars. And so this article, the headline was, questions Mars might answer. So it was a list of what we should ask the Martians when we finally get in touch with them. Well, you would think we would ask them practical questions about building canals or, or maybe how to improve on the airplane of the Wright brothers.
因为毫无疑问，当涉及到机动飞行时，火星人远远领先于我们。不，建议我们问火星的问题是最具存在主义意义的问题。生命的意义是什么？当你死后灵魂会发生什么？我们如何防止人类痛苦？这些是我们对火星人的问题。休息之后，火星狂热退潮，以及为什么这个故事至今仍引起共鸣。
Because surely the Martians are far in advance of us when it comes to motorized flight. No, the questions that were suggested for us to ask Mars were the most existential questions. What is the meaning of life? What happens to the soul when you die? How can we prevent human suffering? These were the questions we had for the Martians. After the break, the Mars fever breaks. and why this story still resonates today.
不要走开。我们回来了，和大卫·巴伦在一起。所以在世纪之交，洛厄尔关于火星的想法处于权力的巅峰，但很快更传统的天文学家看到了这种受欢迎程度，他们只是决定是时候彻底结束所有这些疯狂了。
Stick around. We are back with David Barron. So at the turn of the century, Lowell's ideas about Mars are at the peak of their powers, but pretty soon more traditional astronomers see this popularity, and they just decide it's time to finally put an end to all this craziness.
是的，所以在反运河主义者中，有些人说，火星上的这些线条只不过是光学错觉。这是因为我们正在观察一颗处于我们感知极限的行星。眼睛在连接点，在没有线条的地方看到了线条。因此，其中最著名的反运河主义者之一是爱德华·沃尔特·蒙德（Edward Walter Maunder），他是伦敦格林威治天文台的天文学家。他想出一个非常有趣的实验，看看这是否可能是真的。
Yeah, so among the anti-canalists, there were those who said, these lines on Mars are nothing more than optical illusions. It's the fact that we're looking at a planet at the very limit of our perception. The eye is connecting up dots and seeing lines where there aren't any. And so one of the most prominent of these Antich Canalis was Edward Walter Monder, who was an astronomer at the Greenwich Observatory in London. And he came up with a really interesting experiment to see if this could be true.
他实际上招募了天文台附近一所男校的孩子们、十几岁的青少年，参与一个实验，他拿了一张火星地图，在有运河的地方，他擦掉了运河，所以他擦掉了直线，取而代之的是蜿蜒的河流或仅仅是点画和阴影，自然的东西，
He actually recruited these children, these young teens, at a boys' school right near the observatory to take part of the... in an experiment where he took a map of Mars, and where there were canals, he erased the canal, so he erased the straight lines and replaced them with meandering rivers or just stippling and shading, things that would be natural,
而不仅仅是笔直的灌溉运河。他把这些画挂在教室的前面，并指示男孩们呆在座位上，他们不能走得更近以看得更清楚，从他们所在的地方，画出他们在房间前面看到的东西。他们不知道那是火星地图。
not just a straight irrigation canal. And he had these depictions hung at the front of the classroom, and the boys were instructed to stay in their seats, they couldn't go any closer for a better look, from where they were, to draw what they saw, at the front of the room. They didn't know it was a map of Mars.
他们根本不知道自己在做什么。他们只是被要求尽可能忠实地画出来。嗯，这真的很有趣。房间前面那些能非常清楚地看到画作的人准确地画出了蜿蜒的河流和点画。房间最里面那些离得太远的人，
They had no idea what they were doing. They were just asked to draw it as faithfully as possible. Well, it was really interesting. Those in the front of the room, who could see the drawing very clearly, drew it accurately with meandering rivers and stippling. Those in the very back of the room who were so far away,
他们根本看不清任何细节，完全漏掉了这些特征。房间中间那些能看到有一些精细特征但不知道它们是什么的男孩，画了直线。他们看到了那些非常虚幻的东西。因此这后来成为了，
they really couldn't make out any of the details at all, left those features out entirely. The boys in the middle of the room where they could see that there were some fine features but didn't know what they were, drew straight lines. They were seeing those very illusions. And so this then became,
洛厄尔贬义地称之为火星线条的小男孩理论，他说，好吧，你怎么能信任这些格林威治学校的男孩而不是像我这样有成就的天文学家呢？
Loew called it derisively, the small boy theory of the lines on Mars, which he said, well, how can you trust these Greenwich schoolboys over an accomplished astronomer like me?
我能分辨出幻觉和真实的东西。是的。他有足够的放大倍数来看到一些东西，因此他开始自己连接点。
I can tell the difference between an illusion and what's real. Yeah. He had just enough magnification to see something, and therefore he started connecting the dots himself.
画运河。没错。事实上，蒙德这位做这项研究的天文学家所说的是，他认为为什么
drawing canals. Right. And so in fact, and what Mondar, the astronomer who did the study said was he thought that the reason
直到19th世纪末才有人看到火星上的运河，是因为望远镜不够大也不够好。就好像我们一直在房间后面，看不到火星上的任何细节。然后这些望远镜把我们带到了房间中间，在那里我们可以看到有一些细节
no one had seen the canals on Mars until the late 19th century was because the telescopes weren't big enough and good enough. It was as if we had been in the back
但我们看得并不清楚。他说，当我们进入更好的天文台时，我们将移动到房间的前面，知道那里真正有什么。因此，这个小男孩理论基本上是对洛厄尔的第一击。但他最终是如何被打倒的呢？嗯，所以，我的意思是，在某个时候，整件事都会崩溃，
of the room and couldn't see any details on Mars. And then those telescopes brought us to the middle of the room where we could see there were some details
但这是另一位非常像他的天文学家，有趣的是，另一位富有的业余爱好者，他曾一度相信火星上的运河，然后醒悟过来，发现它们并不真实。所以他的名字叫欧仁·米歇尔·安东尼亚蒂（Eugène Michel Antoniadi）。他原本来自希腊。安东尼亚蒂绘制了这些被运河纵横交错的火星地图。
but we weren't seeing them clearly. And he said, when we get even in better observatories, then we will move to the front of the room and know what's really there. So this small boy theory is basically the first shot across the bow at Lowell. But how did he ultimately end up being taken down? Well, so, I mean, at some point the whole thing would have crumbled,
所以他见过它们。他相信它们。但随着时间的推移，他开始怀疑实际上是不是自己的眼睛在捉弄他。因此，在1909年火星和地球格外接近时，安东尼亚蒂获得了使用巴黎郊外欧洲最大望远镜的机会，在火星最接近地球的几天里检查火星。你不会再有这样好的机会等待15年了。
but it was another astronomer very much like him, interestingly, another wealthy amateur who had for a time believed in the canals of Mars who then woke up to the fact that they weren't really there. So his name was Eugène Michel Antoniati. He was originally from Greece. And Antoniati had made these maps of Mars crisscrossed by the canals.
他极其幸运。其中一个晚上，当巴黎上空的空气死一般寂静时，他正盯着火星。那是观察这颗行星的完美条件。而火星几乎总是这个，在望远镜中是一个晃动的物体，时而对焦时而失焦。火星静静地坐着。他能以令人难以置信的清晰度看到这颗行星的表面。这就是这个知道运河应该在哪里的人。他画过它们。他相信它们。它们就在他应该看到运河的地方。相反，他看到了非常、非常、非常自然的特征。
So he had seen them. He believed in them. But over time, he started to wonder if, in fact, his eyes were playing tricks on him. And so in 1909, when Mars and Earth came especially close together, Antoniati gained access to the largest telescope in Europe, outside Paris, to examine Mars on some of the days when it's at its very closest approach. You were not going to have another good chance like this for 15 years.
所以对安东尼亚蒂来说，这真的就像他看到的一个愿景，他现在要告诉全世界什么是真的。他决定要把洛厄尔拉下马。在那之后，洛厄尔的事情开始真正瓦解。甚至连支持他的人也开始迅速流失，包括斯基帕雷利，他是第一个描述火星运河的人。没错。所以斯基帕雷利在1910年去世前不久，
And he got incredibly lucky. One of those nights, he was staring at Mars when the air over Paris was dead. still. It was perfect conditions for observing the planet. And whereas Mars almost always is this, is this wobbly object in the telescope, comes in and out of focus. Mars was sitting dead still. He could see the planet's surface with incredible clarity. And here's this man who knew where the canals were supposed to be. He had drawn them. He believed in them. They were there where he was supposed to see canals. Instead, he saw very, very, very, natural-looking features.
他说，你知道，这些线条可能完全是自然的，我认为我们应该停止称它们为运河。哇。卡米耶·弗拉马利翁这位启发了洛厄尔并继续相信火星上有生命的法国天文学家正在退缩，不再认为这些线条不仅仅是某种自然线条或幻觉。因此，洛厄尔此刻真的成了最后一个坚守阵地的人。他确实是，但你知道，他只是更加固执地坚持己见，这说明了他的顽固，他的自我。而且我认为有时有一种感觉，你越聪明，你就越应该能够接受真实的东西。但事实上，聪明可以让你在自我欺骗方面变得异常聪明
So Antoni, for him, it really was, it was like this vision he saw, that he was now going to tell the world what was true. And he decided he was going to take Lowell down. And things began to really unravel for Lowell after that. Even people who supported him began to just drop off very quickly, including Scaparelli, who was the first person to describe canals on Mars. Exactly. So Scaparelli shortly before he died in 1910,
因此，在安东尼亚蒂出来说运河通过这架高级望远镜消失了之后，洛厄尔的论点之一是望远镜太好了。它太强大了，它自己的力量正在制造幻觉。所以我不认为我说漏了什么说没有火星人。火星上从来没有过运河。但随着这种想法在洛厄尔生命的尽头获得一些关注，他从未退让过一寸。直到临终前，他都坚称自己是一个受苦的天才，人们可能会怀疑他，但他总有一天会被证明是正确的。我的意思是，把他看作一个怪人和顽固的人是很容易的。
he said, you know, these lines may be perfectly natural, and I think we should stop calling them canals. Wow. Camille Flamaria and the French astronomer who had inspired Lowell and who continued to believe there was life on Mars was backing away from the idea that these lines were anything more than natural lines of some sort or illusions. And so Lowell was really kind of the last one holding the back at this point. He was, but he, you know, he just dug in his heels even more, which speaks to his stubbornness, to his ego. And I think sometimes at a sense that the more intelligent you are, the more you should be able to accept what's real. But in fact, intelligence can make you incredibly smart at diluting
但是，你知道，我从你的书中了解到你对洛厄尔和他的遗产确实有慈善的看法。你能描述一下你对他的整体看法吗？嗯，我的意思是，实际上，这真的很有趣。当我开始写这本书时，我以为我写的是一个警世故事。因为事实上，就人们今天对火星运河的了解而言，通常被认为是科学上的重大失误之一。确实如此。这是一个关于我们如何欺骗自己相信不真实的事情的故事，因为我们希望它们是真的。但实际上这也是一个非常鼓舞人心的故事，因为洛厄尔做了很多好事。想象力很重要。洛厄尔
yourself. So after Antoniati came out and said that the canals disappeared through this superior telescope, one of Lowell's arguments was the telescope was too good. It was too powerful and that its its own power was creating illusions. So I don't think I'm giving anything away to say there are no Martians. He never were canals on Mars. But as that idea started to gain some traction toward the end of Lowell's life, he never gave an inch. He claimed to his dying day that he was this suffering genius who people might doubt, but he would someday be proven right. I mean, it's pretty easy to see him as a kook and a stubborn man.
在这方面拥有丰富的资源。他确实促使人们试图回答火星上发生了什么的问题。他确实做到了。他激发了那个时代的孩子们对太空的热情。我的意思是，事实上，即使在今天的科学家中，这也算是一种分歧。你有那些非常保守的人，他们觉得自己的工作是以非常客观的方式收集数据。然后是那些想要收集数据并想象这一切如何组合成某个宏大理论的人。两者在科学中都非常重要。你需要收集者，你也需要梦想家，那些想象什么是真的人。所以我认为科学中的想象力和梦想可能发生的事情并对此感到兴奋之间有一条细微的界限，但要知道当证据根本不支持这一点时什么时候该退缩。
But, you know, I gather from your book you do have charitable opinions of Lowell and his legacy. Could you describe what you think of him in the totality? Well, I mean, it's actually, it's really interesting. When I went into writing this book, I thought that I was writing a cautionary tale. Because, in fact, to the extent people know about the canals of Mars today, generally remembered as one of the great blunders of science. And it was. It's a story about how we can fool ourselves into believing things that aren't true because we wish they were true. But it actually is also a very inspiring tale because Lowell did a lot of good. Imagination is important. And Lowell had
那是洛厄尔的重大缺点，就是他从来不知道什么时候该退缩。是的，我想今天的人们可能会回想起火星狂热，认为每个人都那么天真和轻信。但当我读你的书时，我发现自己在思考我们今天的世界，我们今天的世界以及我们。我们与科学和真相的充满矛盾的关系。那么洛厄尔的故事让你想到了当下的什么？很多。因此，哈佛法学学者卡斯·桑斯坦（Cass Sunstein）在《新共和》杂志上写了一篇关于我的书的非常有趣的评论文章。
that in spades. And he really did push people to try to answer the question about what's going on on Mars. And he really did. He inspired the children of that era to get excited about outer space. I mean, it's actually, it's a kind of a divide among scientists even today. You've got those who are very conservative who feel their job is to collect data in a very objective way. And then you've got those who want to take the data and imagine how it all fits together into some grand theory. And both are really important in science. You need the collectors and you need the dreamers, those who imagine what's true. So I think there's a fine line between imagination in science and dreaming of what might be and getting excited about it, but knowing when to pull back when the evidence just doesn't support that.
他提到了小罗伯特·F·肯尼迪（RFK Jr.）的名字。我认为这里有有趣的相似之处。在这里，你有一个来自马萨诸塞州最显赫家族的人，他现在，你知道，围绕着对疫苗的怀疑建立了自己的声誉。你知道，科学界的绝大多数人认为这是无稽之谈。你知道，引发这一切并称疫苗与自闭症之间存在联系的研究已被证明是欺诈性的。然而，小罗伯特·F·肯尼迪围绕这个想法建立了自己的身份。许多人发现他很有口才，很有魅力，而且，再次强调，我不能代表他脑子里在想什么。
And that was Lowell's great fault, is that he never knew when to back down. Yeah, I think people today might look back at the Martian craze and think everyone was so naive and gullible. But when I read your book, I found myself thinking about our world today and our world today and our. our fraught relationship with science and truth. And so what does Lowell's story make you think of in the present day? So much. So it was a very interesting essay written about my book in the New Republic by the Harvard legal scholar Cass Sunstein.
但我认为人们可以看到与来自马萨诸塞州显赫家族的珀西瓦尔·洛厄尔的相似之处，他有很多需要证明自己是一个重要人物。他这样做的方式是关于火星生命的这个理论。即使人们试图一点一点地削弱它，他也死不肯让步，因为那会彻底粉碎他的自我。是的。我的意思是，还有这种强迫症，让这些富有、特权的内部人士将自己塑造成正统的异端局外人。为什么，为什么这种叙事如此引人注目？这是一个好问题。
And he brought up the name of RFK Jr. And I think there are interesting parallels there. Here you have someone from one of the most famous. families in Massachusetts, who has now, you know, built a reputation around skepticism on vaccines. You know, most in the scientific community think this is bunk. You know, the very, the study that started this all that said there was a link between vaccines and autism has been shown to have been fraudulent. And yet, RFK Jr. has built his identity around this idea. and he's a lot of people find him very articulate, charismatic, and again, I can't speak for what's going on inside his head.
但是，但是我想说的是，这里有很多人，在这种情况下，将自己塑造成怀疑论者。我完全支持怀疑论。科学应该建立在怀疑论之上。但我经常认为，正是其中一些宣扬怀疑论的人对自己不够怀疑。我们都必须有谦逊的理解，即我们是容易犯错的人类，当我们抓住一个想法时，我们很不情愿放弃它。我的意思是，我做科学记者和作家已经40年了。科学记者报道的大多数事情都是错的，因为你看到的是科学的前沿。
But I think one can see parallels to Percival Lowell from a prominent Massachusetts family, had a lot needed to prove that he was an important person. His way of doing it was this theory about life on Mars. And even as people tried to chip away at it, he was unwilling to give an inch because that would have just crushed his ego. Yeah. I mean, there's also this compulsion of having these ultimate, wealthy, privileged insiders casting themselves as renegade outsiders to orthodoxy. What is, what is, why is that narrative so compelling? That's a good question.
但我认为我们可以看出，这与来自马萨诸塞州显赫家族的珀西瓦尔·洛厄尔有相似之处，他非常需要证明自己是一个重要人物。他的做法就是提出这个关于火星生命的理论。甚至当人们试图对此进行反驳时，他也不肯让步哪怕一寸，因为那会彻底摧毁他的自负。是的。我的意思是，还有这样一种强烈的冲动，即让这些拥有终极财富、特权的内幕人士将自己塑造为正统观念的叛逆外行。为什么，为什么这种叙事如此引人入胜？这是一个好问题。
But, but I guess what I would say is a lot of folks in this, in this situation, cast themselves as skeptics. And I'm all for skepticism. science should be built on skepticism. But I often think that it's some of those people who promote skepticism who are not skeptical enough of themselves. We all have to have the humility to understand that we are fallible human beings who, when we latch on to an idea, are loath to give it up. I mean, I've been a science journalist and writer for 40 years. Most of what science reporters report on is wrong because you're looking at the cutting edge of science.
但是，但我想说的是，处于这种境地中的许多人把自己标榜为怀疑论者。我完全支持怀疑论，科学应该建立在怀疑论的基础之上。但我经常认为，正是其中一些宣扬怀疑论的人，对自己不够怀疑。我们所有人都必须具备谦逊的品质，去理解我们是会犯错的人类当我们迷恋上一个观点时，往往舍不得放弃它。我的意思是，我做科学记者和作家已经40年了。科学记者报道的大多数内容最终都是错的，因为你看到的是科学的最前沿。
You're at that point where something's known, but it hasn't quite been figured out, and people are trying to get better data and coming up with theories, and most of the time, they're wrong. Eventually, we move beyond it, and we can see, in hindsight, which was the right path. It happens all the time, but it doesn't usually happen on quite so grand a scale as it did with Percival Lowe. Well, David Barron, thank you so much for talk with me. I just had a blast reading your book and a blast talking to you through. It was so much fun. Well, Robin, it was my pleasure.
你正处于这样一个阶段：有些事情已知，但尚未完全搞清楚，人们正试图获得更好的数据并提出各种理论，而且大多数时候，它们都是错的。最终，我们会超越它，并且事后我们可以看出哪一条路才是正确的。这种情况一直在发生，但通常不会像帕西瓦尔·洛厄尔那那样规模宏大。好的，大卫·巴伦，非常感谢与我交谈。我读你的书时感到非常愉快，和你交谈也非常愉快。这太有趣了。好的，罗宾，这是我的荣幸。
And with a last name like yours, I figure it was bound to be that I would come on your show. Makes sense to me. 99% Invisible was produced and edited this week by Joe Rosenberg and Jason DeLeon. Mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Rial. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kurt Colstead is our digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Emmett Fitzgerald,
而且以你这样的姓氏，我想我注定会来你的节目。我觉得这很合理。《99%隐形》本周由乔·罗森伯格和杰森·德莱昂制作和剪辑。马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由斯旺·里亚尔创作。凯西2世是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是我们的数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、埃met特·菲茨杰拉德、
Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashamadon, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Tallinn and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Serious XM Podcast Family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown oakland california you can find us on all the usual social media science as well as our own discord server there's a link to that as well as every
克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、拉沙马顿、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·麦地纳·格利森、塔林和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。您可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们，那里有链接以及每一期
past episode of 99 p i at 99 p i dot org There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
过往的《99%隐形》节目，网址是 99pi.org。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。